now to New Orleans where gunfire at one
of the most popular Mardi Gras parades
has killed one man and injured four
other people including a toddler all
four are of the Wounded are hospitalized
and in stable condition police say the
suspect is in custody the shooting
remains under investigation the crew of
Bacchus parade known for its elaborate
floats is always held the Sunday before
Mardi Gras well a pair of weekend
shootings in Memphis killed one person
and injured 10 others police suspect the
shootings are connected the first at a
nightclub early yesterday left two
victims in critical condition officers
at the scene were then notified of a
second shooting roughly a mile away when
police arrived there they found a man
dead at the scene police released photos
of three men they want to talk to but so
far there have been no arrests